many of the stars of super bad were
launched to instant Fame after the movie
became a giant hit but not all of them
were so lucky whatever happened to
Martha mcisaac mcisaac isn't
particularly close to any of the guys
from Superbad but she and Emma Stone
remain near and dear friends having even
spent a few years living together in
2012 mcisaac presented her pal with the
first ever MTV Trailblazer award Emma
has proven herself as one of the most
enduring and captivating actresses of
Our Generation she's a gifted
Entertainer and a very dear friend in
2017 MC Isaac joined fellow actresses
Anna O'Reilly and sugar Lin beard for a
pre-oscars get together with all three
sporting t-shirts and support of Stone's
bid for best actress a couple of months
after the Oscar buzz had died down Stone
and mcisaac went to a relaxing trip to
Sonoma in Northern California a
picturesque City located in the heart of
a world-renowned wine making region